[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est ce vraiment important que les filles
fassent du football le système du genre
s'appuie sur deux piliers
premier pilier les sérotypes de sexe
clichés et injonctions vestimentaire qui
opère une classification entre tous les
êtres humains
d'un côté les femmes d'un côté les
hommes des robes des talons aiguilles du
maquillage des sacs à main pour les unes
et pour les autres plus tôt des
interdits symbolique pas de robe
pas de maquillage pas de talons aiguille
pas de sacs à main vêtements physique
qui se double d'un vêtement social
qu'est ce qu'être une petite fille
qu'est ce qu'être un petit garçon qu'est
ce qu'un jouets de filles
qu'est ce qu'un jouets de garçons qu'est
ce qu'être un homme qu'est ce qu'être
une femme mais aussi qu'est ce qu'être
une mère qu'est ce qu'être un père c'est
serré au type ne disent rien des
inégalités parce que le contraire de
l'égalité n'est pas la différence mais
l'inégalité est alors à part et le
deuxième pilier du genre le sexisme
après avoir consenti collectivement à
cette classification d'un côté les
femmes d'un côté les hommes
nous allons y est rare chizé ces groupes
sociaux de sexe voilà les effets du
stéréotype et du sexisme des bodys des
vêtements qui s'adresse aux bébés entre
0 et 18 mois bébé dont on ne peut
distinguer le sexe alors premiers effets
vestimentaires le rose le bleu
les adjectifs déclinés au féminin et au
masculin
qu'attend-t-on du monde des petites
filles qu'elles soient jolies coq est
belle mais qu'elle soit amoureuse aussi
qu'elle prenne soin qu'elle soit
élégante et attention des attendus sur
le têtu parce que tu es tu c'est
dérangeant c'est embêtant pour le groupe
mais qu'attend t'on du monde des petits
garçons on attend des valeurs sociétales
des valeurs qui font sens dans le
travail la question de la vaillance de
la détermination de la ville t d que des
attendus sociétaux
fonds valeurs humaines la force le
courage l'espièglerie et la ruse qui
font appel à l'intelligence et voilà que
se situe le premier effet du sexisme ce
que françoise héritier a appelé la
valence différentielle des sexes
l'inégal valeur entre le monde des
femmes et le monde des hommes deuxième
effet du sexisme l'imperméabilité des
groupes sociaux de sexe parce que pour
tenir cet ordre social il faut tenir la
distinction
il faut pouvoir immédiatement repéré où
sont les dominer des dominants et alors
l'enjeu est que les hommes
nai jamais jamais dans le groupe dans
les valeurs des femmes qui ne soit pas
perméable qui ne traverse pas qui ne
transpire pas ce monde là parce qu'alors
c'est la honte c'est déchoir c'est ce
que dit iggy pop
je n'ai pas honte de m'habiller comme
une femme parce que je ne pense pas
qu'il soit honteux d'être une femme de
cette inégal valeur entre les femmes et
les hommes vont être toutes les phobies
homophobie lesbophobie transphobie parce
que traverser et comme irréversible et
alors on entendra pour ce petit garçon
qui voudraient une poupée à noël pour ce
petit garçon qui voudraient se déguiser
en fait pour le carnaval
allons ne joue pas comme une fille ne
pleure pas comme une fille était un
bonhomme toi alors jeune rs et c'est
dans mon travail de chercher où sont la
perméabilité des groupes sociaux de sexe
ou dans le loisir des jeunes dans les
cours de récréation dans l'espace public
les femmes et les hommes entrent en
relation se mélangent transpire ensemble
jouent ensemble su ensemble
après avoir analysé plus de 20 me
données statistiques sur l'ensemble du
territoire français
je suis obligé de vous dire que ces
lieux là sont très très peu nombreux il
ya des sport de filles des sports de
garçons des sections féminines des
sections masculine les cours de
récréation sont occupés à l'espace
central par les petits garçons qui
jouent au football et aux petites filles
qui sont relégués sur le côté avec des
malheurs des marelles qu'on leur a
dessiné avec un espace public où
l'ensemble des équipements publics
city-stade skatepark boulodrome s'en
occuper
plus de 90% par les hommes les hommes
occupent l'espace public
les femmes traversent l'espace public
mais alors quelle est la conséquence de
cette norme mixité ça n'est pas un bon
message c'est un message que nous
transmettons nos enfants nous disons la
relation est compliquée la relation est
difficile on ne vous permet pas de vous
mélangez à leur première conséquence de
la non mixité c'est la hiérarchie dans
les loisirs
parce que quand on distingue alors on va
faire le choix de soutenir le loisir des
jeunes garçons on va mettre de
l'équipement on va dédier de l'argent et
enfin - le choix de soutenir les filles
dans leurs loisirs
elles vont être relégué à l'espace privé
mais la conséquence de cette non mixité
pour les filles c'est qu'elle reste
dedans que le monde qui l'aurait
attachée et celui du 2 dans le monde
scolaire et alors ne pas pouvoir passer
le seuil ne pas pouvoir aller dehors
et bien c'est ne pas pouvoir prendre sa
place publique parce que c'est le seul
endroit le dehors qui fait société c'est
le l'endroit de la parole citoyenne
l'endroit de la négociation l'endroit du
vivre ensemble et dû être ensemble
deuxième conséquence de la non mixité
c'est qu'alors dire les filles et les
garçons ne peuvent se mélanger par
exemple dans le loisir sportif sous
couvert d'une inégale performance c'est
dire que toutes les filles entre elles
sont inégales valeur dans la performance
contre tous les garçons nous pourrons
acquérir une technicité la possibilité
de compéti thé avec les autres c'est
dire au monde des garçons vous êtes tous
uniformément meilleur que les filles
mais non parce que dans le monde des
garçons il ya aussi des garçons qui sont
plus fragiles
il y a aussi des garçons en surpoids il
y a aussi des garçons qui sont moins
performants alors il va falloir
rechercher la relation et pour cela je
travaille dans les écoles que me disent
les petites filles lorsque je les
rencontre dans les classes à madame
madame nous on n'a pas le droit de jouer
au football je suis pardon alors on va
discuter ensemble qu'est ce qui fait le
droit qu'est ce qui fait la règle dans
la cour de récréation
ah oui c'est vrai on n'a pas le droit de
jouer dans les toilettes on n'a pas le
droit de se battre on appelle
de s'insulter oui ça mais de jouer au
football tout le monde a le droit et de
ce petit garçon qui est dans une école
où le jeudi eh bien il est interdit de
jouer au football
voilà pour développer d'autres jeux à
qui je demandais toi quoi joue tu as la
récréation et qui me disait le lundi je
joue au football le mardi je joue au
football le vendredi je le joue au
football et le jeudi
je m'amuse parce que oui c'est aussi
ouvrir le monde des possibles entrer en
relation et faire les petits jeux de
fille
alors je vais terminer sur cette phrase
entre eux
j'ai le droit et je veux faire quelque
chose entre l'égalité et la liberté
il y as que je peux le faire et le
pouvoir rendre possible
c'est ce qui nous appartient parce c'est
tim micro espaces publics de la cour de
création
c'est aussi la capacité que nous avons
nous tous ensemble de négocier et de
partager parce que partager ça n'est pas
avoir un gâteau pour chacun ou chacune
d'entre nous c'est bien avoir le même
gâteau et enfer départ et faire départ
c'est renoncer et négocier alors il faut
absolument se mélanger je vais donc vous
poser cette question comme le formule
civière jeune gueye fraysse n'est-il pas
venu le temps du non consentement à cet
ordre social parce que je vous le dis il
n'est plus le temps de lutter ensemble
mais bien de vaincre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]